the episode starts in oslo where a group
of friends are enjoying their time near
the sea as one of them gets ready to
dive into the water he is taken aback by
a mysterious light coming from
underneath soon after three people
emerge from the water looking terrified
the group immediately rescues the three
and contacts the police on the other
hand we are introduced to lars halland a
police officer and his wife who have
recently purchased a new apartment in
the city center as soon as lars signs
the purchase agreement he gets
information about the incident in the
sea and proceeds to the scene upon
reaching there lars notices that the
victims are cold so he gives them some
warm blankets he also believes the
victims are icelandic so he summons for
a translator only to discover that they
speak old norse when the translator asks
where they have come from they reply
that they're from the past hearing this
lars believes that the victims are
mentally ill but when he turns on the
television he sees the news about the
same incident happening all over the
world following this the scene fast
forwards a few years where lars wakes up
in his apartment a radio in the
background reports that the be
foreigners have become a common
phenomenon throughout the world the
foreigners are people from different
time periods who suddenly appear in the
21st century just last year over 13 000
of these cases were reported by the bbc
meanwhile lars appears to be taking a
secret medicine in the form of eye drops
he is also revealed to be divorced and
his wife marie now has a new husband
named gregor's lars's daughter ingrid
lives with her mother but she pays him
frequent visits one day lars learns of a
female before in her who is washed up
dead on the shore of tulholman he along
with his team arrives at the scene
immediately and registers the body in
their database before contacting the
ambulance the body appears to be the
year's 12th floater while investigating
the body lars notices a prehistoric
tattoo on her neck and petechia on her
hip as well as on her eyelids the case
appears to be different because the
forensic believes the cause of death is
strangulation rather than a regular
drowning in the police station the head
officer harold hires a police officer
with a multi-temporal background named f
hildeer and ginstatier later the chief
summons lars and harold to discuss the
appointment of a senior detective to
handle the ongoing before and her death
investigation lars decides to take the
lead on the investigation but harold
refuses because he is currently on sick
leave for chronic drowsiness furthermore
the foreigner cases have already been
heavily criticized and they cannot
afford to appoint the senior detective
who is on sick leave after a bit of
thinking the chief comes up with an idea
to pair lars with f hilder lars believes
that f helder has recently joined and is
thus unqualified for the case but he is
powerless to change the chief's decision
soon after lars and half helder go to
the port police station to find out who
arrived with the victim having the
prehistoric tattoo upon reaching there
they meet with officers jep and david
and ask them if the victim was part of a
group to which they respond no jepp
suggests they go inside the port for
further investigation so they head there
and meet with the other arrivals after a
bit of talking lars displays the dead
girl's photograph and inquires if they
have any information about her one of
the victims recognizes her and confesses
to seeing her in the water she also
claims that hafkufa a sea monster with
glowing eyes tried to capture her
hearing this affhilder believes her
description but lars does not at night
lars goes to a suspicious slaughterhouse
and gets his eye drops after returning
home he investigates the chief holman
case while offhilder contacts him to
inform him of the hafkufa theory if i am
butchering all of these words i am so
sorry although he still doesn't believe
in the theory he asks her to prepare
everything she finds on hafkufa and
present it to the team the following day
on the other hand ingrid intends to
visit rusbus a traditional norwegian
high school celebration but marie and
gregers forbid her claiming that she is
still a minor the following day at the
police station halfhilder shows a
picture of the sea monster to the team
which makes everyone laugh harold then
suggests that she stick to the present
scientific world later affhilder
discovers that a man named tor hund whom
she has been looking for for a long time
is in a restaurant so she rushes there
alone lars notices her departure and
follows her after a while halfhilder
approaches tor and inquires whether he
recognizes her when tor declines she
reminds him of the time that they met
1007 years ago and when he forced
himself on her in a pig pen saying this
much halfhilder starts attacking him
shortly after lars arrives and pulls her
back prompting tor to flee he then
threatens to report her to higher
authorities as the police department
cannot keep a person who is out of
control hearing this halfhilder reveals
that she knows about his secret
medications and addresses him as a temp
addict leaving lars speechless the same
night lars returns home and finds ingrid
on the balcony he asks why she isn't
with her mom to which she replies that
her mother has forbidden her from
participating in rusbus because the
cover name is too crude after learning
about this lars agrees to provide her
with the funds she requires allowing her
to take part in it elsewhere we see two
men in a boat capturing a woman who
emerges from the middle of the sea after
a flash the scene then shifts to the
year 1031 at the fins mark vida plateau
where f helder approaches a small tent
in search of tor upon entering the tent
she notices a blind elderly woman
sitting beside a fire halfhilder
questions her about tor's whereabouts to
which she responds that he once arrived
in search of the lake with multiple
lights halfheelder then asks towards
precise location claiming that he is
everything to her the old woman chuckles
and says that tor is a ladies man and
that she is not the first one to look
for him following that the elderly woman
picks up a tool slices affhilder's palm
sips her blood and begins her occult
ritual after a while she reveals that
tora's in a place where houses are as
tall as mountains and cities shine like
stars back in the present lars who is at
home discovers that the image of the sea
monster is strikingly similar to that of
a fishing trawl bag just then a boy
rushes to his door seeking help for his
father lars goes outside to check and
sees the boy's father being hung on the
stairwell by several men wasting no time
he rushes to stop the man and as soon as
they realize that lars is a cop they
flee the scene after saving the boy's
father lars inquires about those men to
which he replies that they are bohemians
who claim sole authority over drop
selling lars doesn't understand any of
this since the man is from a prehistoric
time the next day at the police station
lars informs offhilder that the picture
of the sea monster looks like a troll
bag he believes that the victim's hip
bruises are caused by the troll bag he
then instructs her to print all troll
sales and look for buyers who aren't in
the industry after a while he comes
across a buyer company named crowmagnan
security elsewhere we see a nude man
named navin who is hunting a bunny in
the woods after the hunt he returns home
and cracks jokes with his wife navin
then heads to the kitchen and eats the
raw bunny ew a few moments later the
same two men from the boat arrive at
navin's house and start discussing about
the beforeing girls they captured from
the sea here it is revealed that the men
work for navin after a bit of discussion
navin directs them to hide the girls in
the hovidoria barracks meanwhile lars
informs his co-worker alex about the
video footage which was recorded near
hovidoya on the night of the murder he
also asks that alex locate additional
footage from the same website just then
marie and gregers approach lars and
confront him about allowing ingrid to
participate in rusbus marie believes
that he has severely breached the trust
and decides to file a case against him
on the other hand alf hilder receives a
call from the national gallery informing
her that the person in custody is
willing to speak with her she then goes
to the national gallery where she
notices a woman being handcuffed by
security the woman is revealed to be
none other than f hilder's elder sister
f holder inquires about the reason for
her arrest to which she responds that
she ripped a false drawing of tor worth
thousands of dollars expectedly this
upsets offhilder and she refuses to
release her sister but the latter
reminds her of her past when she saved
her in bjarmoland because of this how
hilder approaches the gallery owners and
persuades them to withdraw their
complaint claiming that the woman in
custody is intending to sue for ptsd
triggering soon after the two sisters go
to a bar to celebrate their reunion at
home lars is watching the cctv footage
of hovodaya that alex sent him a few
moments later the man whom he rescued
earlier arrives at his place with
various foods as a token of gratitude
looks like a smorgasbord lars invites
the men and his son inside and converses
with them he inquires about the man's
wife to which he responds that she died
on the way to the city causing him to
become emotional being the kind person
that he is lars tries to console the man
and even addresses him as a friend this
makes the man happy as no one has ever
called him a friend before during their
conversation lars notices a tattoo on
the man's hand and inquires about it the
man simply responds that it represents
the family meanwhile the two sisters
proceed to a dance bar but on the way
alf hildier notices a cro-magnon
security van and decides to follow it
the van pulls over to a bar and navin's
two men enter inside the two men
approach the bar owner and demand that
all of the girls they supply to be
returned initially the owner refuses
because his business will suffer without
the girls but the men threaten him with
navin's name leaving him with no other
options outside alfielder secretly
photographs the van the men and the
beforein girls the following day at work
alfieldier shows those pictures to her
team and suspects that the before and
women captured from the sea are being
used as prostitutes and that the murder
is connected to it following this lars
and dalf hilder begin spying on the van
elsewhere navin's wife throws a business
party to celebrate her blogging success
a few moments later navin notices the
bar owner approaching outside his place
and walks out to meet him the owner
demands that the girls be returned or
else the bohemian will take action
against him this enrages navin and he
chokes the bar owner however when he
notices his wife on the balcony he lets
him go meanwhile lars and alfielder
notice navin's men smuggling drugs and
the latter asks if they should apprehend
them lars tells her to wait and the two
follow the men to a place where several
beforeinger women are apprehended taken
aback lars immediately decides to save
the women the officers then chase after
the perpetrators and after a bit of back
and forth the bad guys are finally
subdued while rescuing the victims lars
notices the exact tattoo on one of the
be foreigners that he saw on the man's
hand earlier he tries to ask the woman
about the tattoo but she is unable to
understand his language later at the
police station lars interrogates one of
navin's men but he doesn't reveal
anything lars then summons the man he
saved along with his son to the police
station and allows them to meet the
woman with the same tattoo the woman
appears to be the man's wife and they
are all overjoyed to be reunited at
night lars is working late in the office
and alfieldier joins him as they watch
the video footage they discover that the
deceased girl of chewfulmen appears
beside the sea four hours before her
death this shocks the duo as until now
they had believed that the foreigners
only traveled from the past in the
following scene we see tor who has
surprisingly become a food delivery man
on his way to his delivery he is
distracted by a woman causing him to
fall off his bicycle he then goes to a
nearby restroom to clean up the ruined
food simultaneously a cleaner named skog
enters and recognizes tor from the
prehistoric world however tor pretends
to be unaware of it and walks away on
the other hand lars and alfielder go to
the forensic lab where the forensic
expert reveals that the deceased girl is
not a pre-historian despite her best
efforts to appear different she is a
modern woman following this they go to
the trans-temporal community believing
that the victim has ties to it when they
arrive they are asked to leave their
electronic devices outside because the
residents are allergic to electricity
these guys must be good at cards
reluctantly the duo place their laptops
and cell phones in a box and enter while
the two are interrogating inside a young
lady retrieves all of the case's
information from lars's laptop later in
the police station the officers learn
about holger so they decide to apprehend
him before he flees lars and dolph
hildier are given pistols in order to
catch him meanwhile holger is preparing
to escape by diving into the sea but
just then the police arrive and arrest
him following this he is brought to the
police station where lars and alfielder
question him about the chuff holmen
murder case but he appears to have no
idea despite this he tells them about
navin but before he can elaborate he
falls asleep after some time lars orders
alpha deer to keep her gun in the locker
in the process alfielder accidentally
pulls the trigger causing the bullet to
strike lars's feet you've got to be
kidding me with this he is rushed to the
hospital for treatment meanwhile ingrid
is with her friend at home and the two
are enjoying each other's company ingrid
opens her father's drawer and reveals
his secret eye drops which intrigues her
friend as the two are fooling around
lars and alfielder arrive outside
prompting them to quickly put away the
eye drops however when ingrid goes to
open the door her friend steals an eye
drop bottle secretly shortly after
alphildia prepares food for everyone and
she quickly bonds with ingrid and her
friend while assisting lars with the
dishes alf hildier inquires a personal
question about the service's stance on
intimate relations amongst co-workers
she then reveals that she has been
communicating with the harbour cop jeb
she also claims that they've been
sending each other private photos which
surprises lars meanwhile ingrid and her
friend are staring at them suspecting
that there is something between them on
the other hand skog approaches alpha
alphildier's sister nora and tells her
about tor later nora informs alfhildir
of the same but the latter is skeptical
that tor will be working as a food
delivery man the two sisters then decide
to go to his house to verify that it is
the person they know surprisingly he
appears to be married and has a child
when tor meets them he mentions that he
is suffering from memory loss but they
remind him of everything claiming to be
norse women however the conversation
scares tor so he threatens to call the
cops forcing the sisters to leave after
this alfhildir learns that her sister
has cancer which breaks her heart
however she persuades nora to get the
treatment and encourages her to fight it
claiming that they are shield maidens
and are born to fight the following day
at work alfielder informs lars that
seven people in oslo are registered as
navin but one of them is a wealthy
prehistorian who lives with his wife in
a large house in holmen colon she also
discloses that the two men they
apprehended on the island work for navin
they then go to navin's house and
inquire if he knows anything about the
two men they have arrested as expected
he lies and says no lars knows that he
is lying but he lacks evidence to back
up his claim and as a result they leave
meanwhile the same young lady who stole
data from lars laptop is seen spying on
them from afar as soon as they are gone
the lady approaches navin and reveals
that she knows the woman his men fished
out of the sea she attempts to blackmail
him in exchange for information but he
just goddamn chokes her surprisingly she
manages to counter-attack him saying
that the jungle is not as simple as he
believes before leaving she says that
she will suggest a safer meeting place
for conversation the next day lars
visits ingrid's school to discuss
marie's disagreement about ingrid's
graduation celebration he wants his
daughter to have a normal graduation
ingrid also sides with her father
allowing lars to win the discussion
gregor's to their surprise appears to
agree with lars's statement on the other
hand nora meets with tor once more but
the latter is still uninterested in
speaking with her as soon as he leaves
she notices an unknown car following tor
and learns that he is in danger soon
after she summons elf hildir and the two
sisters set out for tour meanwhile the
men in the unknown car lead torr into an
empty basement parking lot and smack him
with a rod tor asks who they are and
they respond that they're olaf the
stouts men they're about to finish off
tour but he begs them not to do so tired
of his whining the men decide to run him
over instead as tor lies on the floor
crying he starts remembering his past as
a mighty warrior because of this he gets
up with vengeance on his mind and beats
up the two thugs causing them to flee
soon the two sisters approach him who
asks them to provide more information on
tor hooned hearing this the sisters
finally realized that tor has actually
lost his memory at the police station
the women from the transtemporal
community arrive with a man who
recognizes the deceased woman he claims
that the woman came to his styling
studio to get her makeup done as she
wanted to look like a prehistorian the
man further reveals that some days after
her death a man by the name of navin
called him and inquired about the woman
in the final scene we see navin on one
of his usual hunting trips as he is
after a rabbit a drone suddenly arrives
and shoots him to death special delivery
[ __ ]
to see what happens next watch the
second part in series recap